you all need to respect zom check this
out so zom is Immortal and cannot age or
die from natural causes zom possesses
immense physical strength and durability
that exceeds that of the Incredible Hulk
he can manipulate and control various
forms of energy including cosmic energy
and the energy of the Soul he has the
ability to manipulate reality and bend
it to his will he can manipulate time
allowing him to travel through it and
even change its course he can teleport
himself and others through time and
space he can manipulate the structure of
matter allowing him to reshape objects
and even create new ones he can read the
thoughts of others and communicate
telepathically and he has the ability to
heal others by channeling cosmic energy
in fact this guy was so powerful the
only way he could be defeated is the
Living Tribunal had to lock him away
make sure you guys follow for more